[Musique]
qui mieux que Versailles pour embrasser
la cause de l'histoire demande François
deasier le maire de versaill et
coocréateur avec l'écrivain Étienne de
montéti du salon histoire de lire qui se
déroule cette année le 25 et 26 novembre
le salon ce sont des auteurs célèbres
des historiens plus de 20000 visiteurs
mais aussi une centaine de bénévoles qui
ne comptent pas leur temps pour assurer
la réussite de cette histoire de lire
mais comment se prépare-il à cet
événement suivez-nous nous allons entrer
ensemble dans les coulisses de cette
préparation madame de CRP que je ne vois
plusu voilà 70 haute et Hautesse pendant
tout le le weekend alors je vais le
faire peut-être dans l'ordre où vous êes
tout a commencé le 8 novembre dernier à
l'Académie des sciences morales des
lettres et des arts de Versailles où
l'équipe histoire de lire réunissait ses
bénévoles une occasion comme l'explique
le commissaire et organisateur du salon
viané malin perruqué pour la
circonstance de donner le signal du
départ on rassemble toutes nos équipes
il y a plus d'une centaine de de de
bénévoles versaillais pour l'essentiel
qui qui s'impliquent pour faire que
l'accueil de ces auteurs de ces invités
prestigieux soit le le meilleur possible
donc voilà on est on est à leur
disposition et puis y a aussi beaucoup
de gens qui vont animer des des
rencontres donc qui ont lu depuis des
semaines et des semaines 1 2 3 livres et
qui vont animer ces
débats faire parler de son livre et on
ESS coller à l'événement efferv dans
académie où certains ont déjà revêtu
leur habit de lumière ou de cérémonie
car comme l'explique Vian et malin
l'ambiance lié à cette manifestation
d'histoire cette fête de l'histoire
passe aussi par une une mise en costume
beaucoup de ces ces bénévoles deviennent
devienent un personnage enend doos un
costume et pas que du grand siècle il y
aura peu d'hommes de Cromagnon torsonu
mais parce qu'il fait froid ou fin
novembre mais voilà l'idée c'est aussi
qu'on casse la glace avec le public
parce qu'on est accueilli par des gens
souriants et qui nous emmènne dans une
époque c'est le cas de Jean-Baptiste
favatier qui sera cette année le riche
lieu du salon j'ai interprété un certain
nombre de personnages très différents
taléran Vergen et là cette année
j'incarne
Richelieu dans une table ronde avec un
auteur qui vient d'écrire un livre sur
la conjuration de 5 mars qui est un
moment important de la relation
vieillissante entre Louis XI et
Richelieu pourquoi c'est dég ce côté
théâtral le futur richeolieu l'explique
quand il se souvient qu'il a été aussi
talérant le fait de pouvoir incarner un
personnage avec un auteur est une
manière de rendre l'histoire vivante et
et je suis frappé chaque année de voir
que ça rencontre beaucoup de succès
auprès du public un échange avec un
auteur anglais d'un livre sur Taleran il
se trouve que c'est un personnage que
que je connaissais bien j'étais costumé
en Taleran et assez vite on est sorti du
livre pour avoir une conversation dans
laquelle j'étais complètement dans la
peau du personnage je complétais
l'auteur je corrigeais ce qu'il disait
lui s'était mis dans la partie ça a été
un moment délicieux lui n'a pas encore
revêtu le costume mais il s'apprête à le
faire en devenant celui qui fut
président de la République et qui habité
la préfecture de Versailles que do
queedo vous voyez de qui il s'agit non
ben voici la réponse je vais me déguiser
la demande des organisateurs en maréchal
de France et en plus président de la
République pu c'est Patrice mcmaahon qui
a habité à la préfecture de de versaill
en tant que président de la République
en
1873 donc j'aurai un petit mot à dire
sur l'histoire de cette maison
l'histoire triste avec l'occupation
prussienne et puis l'histoire plus
récente avec la préfecture de de
Versailles un salon d'histoire donc se
dit-on plutôt un publicque d'un certain
âge pas seulement comme l'explique yolen
tini bénévole pour le salon et en an
dans la vie les jeunes ont aussi leur
espace ce qui m'a motivé au départ
c'était mon amour pour la lecture et
pour l'histoire
et j'ai commencé la première année avec
l'espace des auteurs adultes et la
deuxième année on m' proposé l'espace
jeunesse puisque je suis enseignante et
que j'aime beaucoup la littérature
jeunesse témoin de ce rajunisement le
prix des youtubeurs auquel participent
des dizaines de lycéens passionnés
d'histoire et dont le vainqueur viendra
présenter son film sur tv78 c'est là un
changement qui a impressionné notre
cardinal ce qu'il a remarqué c'est
l'extraordinaire développement du livre
du salon sur la cible de la jeunesse qui
amène des bénévoles très jeunes autour
d'événements YouTube et autres qui qui
qui sont à la fois l'avenir du salon
mais plus encore l'avenir de l'histoire
Bruno Solo revient Maxime d'Aboville
revient Laurent Dutch voici donc ces
bénévoles sur le pied de guerre et prêts
au combat parce qu'ils le savent une
partie de la réussite du salon repose
sur eux j'aime à dire que souvent euh
l'image du salon c'est c'est c'est
d'abord le visage de toute C cette
équipe cette armée ces petites abeilles
euh voilà à à l'accueil à l'entrée à
l'hôtel de ville à l'hôtel du du
département à la Chambre de Commerce et
puis c'est aussi ce ce Lian cette
relation en permanence parce que les
auteurs eu même pas que le public peuv
être un petit peu perdu il y a aussi des
jeunes auteurs qui viennent pour la
première fois qui ne savent pas ce que
c'est qu'un qu'un salon voilà donc on va
les décontracter leur offrire des petits
cafés des petits des petits biscuits on
va leur montrer qu'on qu'on a aimé leur
livre qu'on l'a lu et et voilà et et du
coup il y a une une ambiance une osmose
qui se qui se fait et ça c'est grâce à
cette centaine de de petites abeilles
qui qui
s'impliquent on continue à une dizaine
de jours de l'ouverture du salon
quelques bénévoles toujours sous la
oulette du commissaire malin se retrouve
dans un des lieux importants de ce salon
l'hôtel de Madame Dubarry qui abrite
aujourd'hui la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie mais qui prêtera le temps
d'un weekend quelques-unes de ces salles
aux auteurs et au public donc c'est ici
qu'il y aura l'espace histoire 2.0 vous
savez c'est l'espace qui est dédié aux
youtubeurs qui sont là depuis 6 ans sur
le salon mais donc ils seront ici nous
aurons les six finalistes qui
présenteront leur
vidéos nous aurons aussi donc les je
jeux vidéo nous aurons nos modélisateurs
du patrimoine le dimanche les deux
écrans qu'on voit là ils seront démontés
où on pourra les utiliser on pourra les
utiliser pour retransmettre justement
toutes les modélisations 3D les vidéos
nous aurons aussi le long métrage le
93e réalisé par des jeunes de 18 ans ça
devrait attirer beaucoup les les jeunes
générations et faire découvrir aux
autres tout ce qu'on peut faire autour
de l'histoire voilà on va laisser les
bénévoles prendre en repos bien mérité
avant le rush du weekend prochain on
viendra les surveiller pour savoir si
tout va bien histoire de dire c'est
[Musique]
chaleureux